I am dating someone exclusively I'm so
excited to show you guys pictures and
everything in a little bit right now I'm
just keeping him to myself though and I
will let you guys know a little bit more
information later but just ah so excited
Christine Brown's mystery man is no
longer a mystery the Sister Wives star
making the big reveal on Valentine's Day
I started moving forward and I just
don't I don't I didn't look back I never
looked back Christine is Instagram
official with her boyfriend David
Woolley sharing these first photos
together and the caption says it all I
foundly found the love of my life David
the first time he held me close it felt
like my soul took its first breath he's
wonderful and romantic and so kind and
everything I've been looking for
incredible with truly yeah it seems
David's got the family stamp of approval
check out this pick of the couple
holding Christine's daughter mckelty's
twins Ace and Archer Christine calls
David wonderful and kind incredible with
my children and an adorable Grandpa and
ends her post saying I never dreamed I
could find a love like this he's
absolutely a dream come true as for
David those feelings are mutual he
posted this sweet selfie with Christine
and calls her my queen after everything
you've been through what is it you're
looking for in a new partner
um kindness
um real just kindness and romantic
relationship for sure someone's who's
attracted to me would be a really great
thing I'm just saying so yeah all of
that looks like Christine's found that
in David more than a year following her
split from ex-husband Cody nobody's a
prisoner in this family their messy
split played out on the Family's reality
show just the knife in the kidneys over
all these years and the sacrifices that
I made to love you I firmly believe
plagued me was what I was supposed to do
and everything and that felt great and
now though yeah I get to be done so it's
more like a personal strength that I
feel like I have more than I've ever
felt before
[Music]